when you email someone you should
receive a response there are a lot of
courses out there on motion design and
it's important when you reach out with a
question or a comment you receive a
response unfortunately not all courses
and course platforms are created equal I
have heard over and over again that
students who take courses from some very
well-known course creators never receive
responses we're the good guys because at
motion science we believe that our
students deserve the best possible
experience that's why we make sure to
respond to every single one of our
students questions we understand how
important it is to be heard and we want
to make sure that our students feel
supported every step of the way when you
have a question or you need help with
something you can be sure that myself or
someone from our team will respond to
you in a timely manner if you're looking
for a motion design course that will
make you feel supported and confident in
your skills look no further than motion
science